hello I'm Susan - Stein and I am at Penn
State University Park in the Department
of Biochemistry and molecular biology
and in this first slide you can see me
standing next to a giant cryo electron
microscope so this is the Titan crius
and we use this microscope to collect
data to solve 3d reconstructions
so the project I'm going to talk about
today is using Crimea as a structural
analysis to understand how canine
parvovirus or CPB uses the transferrin
receptor and how this contributed
contributes to species jumping
so here on this slide I'm showing the
people who did the work on the Left
panel from left to right we have Surya
Dan and Hume walk Hume look is the one
who did all the reconstructions in my
lab on the right panel from left to
right we have Robert Ian and Colin
collin parish's lab is at cornell and
they collaborated with us on this
project
so prior to the late 1970s there was an
aversion of parvo virus that infected
dogs
the first parvo viruses are canine
parvovirus is that arose in the late 70s
started causing pandemics and which
means they swept across the world
while we when we started studying canine
parvovirus in collaboration with collin
parish's lab we found that there were
mutations between the feline version and
the canine version and originally we
thought that the virus must have jumped
species from cats to dogs since then
we've done more work and found that it's
a little more complicated than that
and it seems probably likely that the
virus jumped species from cats to
raccoons and then to dogs we were able
to map on the capsid surface the areas
the mutations where the mutations
cluster and we're able to deduce that
that is where the receptor binds
so as the through history as the virus
has circulated we've found that it
infects quite a number of carnivores and
you see the the tree on the left that
shows the relationship of these
different variants of the virus and on
the right we show a number of canines
and the virus can infect the TFR
transferrin receptors of all these
different species and doing some binding
assays we found that the transferrin
receptor for the black pack jackal and
that's the canine in the center of that
group binds the the capsid with pretty
high affinity so we picked that for
these structural studies going into the
studies we have a lot of information
about canine parvovirus capsids there
are multiple crystal structures and
high-resolution cryo-em structures from
which we can base this work
and there's also some information on the
transferrin receptor itself the Martin
Lawrence solved the crystal structure of
human TF are shown on the left and it's
made up of three basic domains up at the
top it has a well overall it has this
sort of butterfly shape so the tips of
the butterfly wings that's the apical
domain and we know that's the portion
that binds to the virus capsid then
there's sort of a sensor domain where
you see the two wings wrapped together
to make this butterfly shape and that's
a very stable structure so this is a
dimer but it's never found as a monomer
and solution we we typically see it as a
very stable dimeric complex on the right
is a structure from yifan chain that
shows TFR binding it's it's natural
ligand which is transparent so the
transparent are arranged around the
outside of the TFR molecule so that they
will bind at the wing region and I'll
show you more about this a little bit
later so this diagram shows different
species of TF are lined up together
and the things to note here is they are
very similar blue highlights we show a
couple of glycosylation sites for the
canine version of TFR and then we know
this red site the site outlined in
orange or red there is a very critical
one for virus binding
this project was first started back in
2007 and this very low resolution
structure shown on this slide that
previous work we have a fairly low
resolution structure where we show one
PFR in the red green and yellow one TFR
bound to the virus capsid it's sort of
blobby but I think that more important
things that we learn from this structure
was because the TFR molecule is so large
relative to the size of the capsid that
only a few receptors can bind it
probably can't get more than 20
receptors on a capsid at any one time
because there just will crash into each
other and prevent binding next to a
next-door neighbor we also found that
when we worked with the complexes if we
use more than about ten TFR per capsid
that ratio led to aggregation so we knew
moving forward that we'd have to focus
on solving this structure and in a
symmetric way so using our black-backed
jackal purified TFR and purified canine
capsids we made an incubation of about
40 FRS per each capsid then we vitrified
that solution and that robot for
vegetation is shown in the center and
then collected data on using the titan
kriyas
this is an image that shows a micrograph
this is the output from the Titan koreas
so this is that the complex shown as a
2d projection in a raw micro-cap
micrograph and the little boxed areas
are blown up on the right and you can
see the outline of the capsid and then
make out some TFRs bound to it so we had
about almost 4,000 micrographs and we
were able to collect one hundred and
fifty four thousand particles or so from
this data set and we use those for the
3d reconstruction even though there's
only there about forty FRS per capsid
but the first thing we did was average
all over the capsid to get as high
resolution as we possibly could and when
we do that those few TFRs that are bound
sort of just averaged out we don't see
them but we get a really nice
reconstruction of the capsid alone and
that's what's shown here to the right is
a single structural protein and we can
look at that in comparison with the
crystal structures and see that there's
no massive or global conformational
change induced by the binding of the
receptor but we did see some other
change and that's shown here so on the
left is canine parvovirus or CPV alone
it's never been incubated with receptor
and on the right is the map that I just
showed you but these two maps are
rendered differently so the color code
color code corresponds to flexibility
anything that's blue and grading toward
white and red so the blue is is very
stable and white is much more flexible
and you can see that the capsid alone is
very rigid and stable but after the
transferrin receptor has bound the
capsid parts become more flexible or
more dynamic and that's shown on the
right
you
so now if we go back to the the
icosahedral map shown here or the
averaged map
we want to probe this map and find where
the TFRs are bound so in order to do
that we're going to do a focused
refinement or first we're going to start
with a simbra approach and I'm going to
describe that in the next slide so the
there's six little maps shown here and
the one that's called Enosh or it for
initial is the map we used as a model to
start with so basically we took a low
resolution model of the transferrin
receptor and just stuck it on to the
capsid and we use this as a search model
and that icosahedron a a virgin map and
so we were searching the map trying to
line up and find the locations of the
various one to four bound transferrin
receptors basically we're rotating the
map looking for where TFRs are bound
relative to the capsid and the outputs
are shown in the first third fifth
seventh and ninth iterations of this
process and this is called a symmetry
mismatch approach and you can see by the
ninth iteration that we've sort of
aligned all the bound TFRs into the same
orientation and sort of piled that
density on top of itself to show a
single asymmetric map of the virus with
TFR bound
so that showed us or confirmed for us
that the binding event did take place at
the tip or that apical domain of the TFR
and at the tip of the threefold spike on
the virus we have a very nice high
resolution capsid structure it's near
atomic resolution the receptor density
is is better than our first blob ology
that I showed you before from 2007 but
we are hoping to improve it the first
thing we noticed was there's too much
volume for just TFR now on the next
slide I show you what I mean so now if
show you two views the capsid is down
below and the TFR density is more in the
center and on the left you see the
butterfly turns 90 degrees and see this
extra density around it when in the
right view you can see the butterfly
sort of weighing on and you see that
cluster of density unfilled density
above well we know from Yvonne Chang
structure that this is this unfilled
density is where TF transferrin binds to
the transferrin receptor so our
transferrin receptor had TF already
associated with it when it bound to the
virus we went back to the purified TF r
alone and we did charge detection mass
spectrometry and this showed that an
analysis of purified TF r showed that we
had free TF r with one TF bound and
somewhat two TF TF molecules bound and
the peak at the left might be where TF r
has dissociated which is sort of
unexpected to us in this complementary
experiment
moving forward
now we want to look at the interaction
between the receptor and the virus
capsid and when we zoom into this the
virus ISM is below and the TFR is above
in green we can see that at this site of
the interaction the density isn't very
good and so now to the right we see a
map that's rendered according to
resolution red is good high resolution
and you can see the capsid is mostly red
but as you start looking at the TFR
that's bound there the resolution
quickly becomes quite poor but now true
there's only a few TFRs compared to the
number of capsules we have but this
isn't anywhere near as good as what we
would expect we would expect it to be a
little better so we continued the
analysis so the first thing we did with
this analysis was the focused
classification so that means we masked
an area and we masked off an area
corresponding to the TFR volume and what
we found with this first round of focus
classification was occupied and
unoccupied TFR binding sites
then with the we did a second round a
focus classification and here we found
that there are multiple ways that TFR
binds relative to the capsid so in that
volume the TFR is actually taking on
different orientations relative to the
capsid so there's different positions of
the TFR adjacent to the capsid so if we
link all of these different orientations
together we actually see that there's
movement so the TFR binds the capsid
with a very dynamic movement it actually
rocks in three different directions and
there's a slight rotation so in the lab
we started calling this the
rock-and-roll receptor
the next thing we wanted to do was get
the very best resolution reconstruction
of TFR that we could so we released it
from the context of the capsid and just
did a reconstruction on TFR alone we got
to about 6 angstrom resolution which is
good enough to do the fitting so what we
did here was fit the crystal structure
salt solved by martin lawrence into the
cryo-em density and now we can put it
back into the context with the capsid
and interpret that interphase and that's
shown on the next slide so this is what
we call a road map and you can just
barely see the black triangle that
outlines one repeating subunit on the
surface of the virus the outlines show
the receptor binding site of TFR on the
capsid so we've changed the terminology
since I made this slide because outlined
in red are the sites that are consistent
between every binding mode as the TFR
sort of rocks and rolls on the capsid so
we always have those interactions the
ones outlined in yellow change a little
bit as the virus receptor rocks and
rolls then the two pictures on the right
show where the TFR is binding the capsid
so that's a TFR rotated and unrotated to
show the interactions of the different
amino acids on it on the transferrin
receptor
so the take-home message here is that we
believe that the variability with which
the capsid can interact with TFR is
really a driving force for the evolution
and explains how this virus can jump
species and use different species TFR
and still infect a cat a dog or
black-backed jackal
the last slide is another picture
showing acknowledgments for my lab
collin parish's lab and of course our
funding agencies this ends my talk but I
understand in this format there will be
questions and I'll be glad to follow up
with those questions by email